we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p yesterday we
talked about when it comes to people who
hear trump talk about injecting bleach
and they go and they ingest bleach
should we care about that is it a
Darwinian thinning of the herd should we
not care about the plight of the conned
here's a voicemail about exactly that
issue hey david geffen oregon hey i
heard you say suggesting that we should
absolve trump's followers that but my
take is is there is no con man without
suckers
there is no cult leader without cult
followers certainly republican
politicians who know better should be
held criminally culpable that his
followers need to be deprogrammed and
let's look in the mirror and say what
they've caused
listen i am not trying to absolve people
who go and inject bleach of any
responsibility but the caller says they
need to be deprogrammed well that means
that they've been programmed to begin
with and they didn't program themselves
so I think that there's plenty of blame
to go around we have an education system
that is failing people we have a
political system that is failing people
we have an economic system that is
failing people I'm not looking to
absolve anybody of the actions that they
choose to take and of personal
responsibility but I do stop short of
saying hey let's absolve the con men of
any responsibility and simply criticize
those who have been conned that doesn't
seem right to me either
we've got a terrific bonus show for you
today don't miss it become a member or
patron today to get instant access I'll
talk to you then or otherwise tomorrow